I'm really excited for the 2016 Sundance
Film Festival first up the directors
Sundance is the perfect place for
up-and-coming directors and veteran
helmers to show up their unique style I
can't wait to see what indie legends
with Gilman iris acts and 12 salons have
hooked up as well as check out the
film's maybe five female directors in
the dramatic competition and before he
directs the next full movie you can see
Kiwi Taika Waititi at Sundance with hunt
for the will the people next the actors
the film's feature of Sundance offer
big-name stars a chance to try something
different I'm looking forward to seeing
Daniel Radcliffe Paul Rudd Michelle
Williams and Kristen Stewart with their
new films and I'm also interested to see
the directorial efforts of actors John
Krasinski Diego Luna clear Duvall and
Nate Parker who's the birth of a nation
is sure to make it flash then there's
the documentary Sundance is known for
raising some of the best and most
interesting documentaries around and
this year a couple of unique choices
immediately stand out I went to see
Spike Lee's Michael Jackson duck
becoming Mike Nichols they talked about
the late great the Graduate Helmer and
one called
tickles about the weird weird world of a
tickling competition yep and don't
forget about the short films among
sleuth year's lineup of 72 short film
choices are movies directed by Jason
Reitman and Bryce Dallas Howard as well
as some shorts exploring hot-button
topics like the Ferguson shooting and a
quirky animated film called simply Bob
Dylan hates me
about why you should never in your idols
and last but definitely not least be
midnight screenings this is quite
possibly the most fun I have ever had at
Sundance these crazy Horrors and wacky
are perfect to sleep with packs proud
latest night two films definitely on my
radar a 31 by Rob Zombie and yoga hoses
by Kevin Smith as we call or spin-offs
of sorts to get freaky film buffs
I cannot wait those are my reasons to be
excited for Sundance but what about
yours let us know in the comments below
and make sure you subscribe to Fandango
movie clips I'm alone